Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Evet,
kendi ana dilimle size kendimi tanıttım.
İki çocuk annesiyim,
40 yaşındayım,
işaret dili çevirmeniyim,
ayrıca bir kodayım.
Koda, annesi ve babası
işitme engelli olan çocuklara deniyor.
Yani duyan ve konuşan çocuklara.
Bu meslek,
benim hayatımın kahramanlarını
bana verdiği en büyük...
Şöyle söyleyeyim,
dezavantajımı avantaja çevirmemin
en büyük destekçisiydi kahramanlarım;
kahramanlarım annem ve babam.
Onlar sayesinde
Türk İşaret Dili'ni öğrendim.
Zorunda, "zorundalıkla" öğrendim
aslında, zorunlulukla demeyelim de.
Onlar sayesinde öğrendim
ve şu an buradayım.
Bununla ilgili o kadar çok anı,
o kadar çok hikâye,
o kadar çok şey var ki;
ama ben size seçmeceler,
kendi nezdimce seçmeceler yaptım
ve bunları küçük küçük
hızlıca anlatacağım.
Ben şanslı bir kodayım,
bunu söylemeden geçemeyeceğim,
çünkü benim bir abim
ve bir ablam vardı.
Ablam ve abim
çok zor zamanlar geçirdiler,
ama ben çok rahattım.
Yaramazdım, gevezeydim, bilmiştim.
Bu bizim ailenin en yaramaz çocuğu
olarak ben vardım.
Bir gün annem, babam ve ablam,
arkadaşı herkes evde.
Ablamla arkadaşı mutfakta,
ben salonda yaramazlık peşindeyim.
O sıra, öyle bir durum oluyor ki
ben ne yaptığımı
hatırlamıyorum tabii şu an.
Ablamın anlatmasıyla,
onun ağzıyla anlatıyorum.
Televizyon sırtıma düşüyor
ve ben o çığlıkla
"Abla!" diye haykırıyorum.
Ablam mutfaktan salona doğru koşarken
bir afallıyor.
Neslihan acaba hangi yaramazlığı yaptı,
ayrıca Neslihan neden
"Anne!" diye bağırdı?
Bu ona böyle çok tuhaf geliyor
ve ilginç geliyor.
Sonradan anlıyoruz ki ikimiz de,
normalde bir çocuk
ilk önce anne diye bağırır,
ama benim annemin
beni duymayacağını bildiğim için,
öncelikle abla dedim,
çünkü tek sesimi
duyuracağım insan ablamdı
ve ondan sonra,
şöyle yapmaya başladım.
Büyümeye başladım, gelişiyorum.
Annemle babamın sağır olduğunu
kabul etmeye başladım,
duymuyorlar evet.
Yani annem ve babam sağır.
Günlerden hafta sonuydu sanırım,
akrabamızı ziyarete gidiyoruz.
Akrabalarımızı ziyarete giderken
otobüse biniyoruz
ve otobüste normalde o zamanlar
engelliler için
ücretsiz kartlar başlamıştı.
Annem kartını gösteriyor,
ben normal geçiyorum,
babam tam geçecek,
muavin babamla münakaşaya girmiş,
tartışıyorlar.
Babam diyor ki,
"Ben duymuyorum."
Muavin hâlâ bir şey anlatıyor.
Babam diyor ki,
"Ben duymuyorum.
Niye anlatıyorsun bana?"
Babam o stresle ne anlattığını anlamadan
muavinin yakasından tutuyor,
oturduğu yerden kaldırıp.
Bir bakmışız otobüsün dışında kendisi
kapıdan dışarı gidiyor
ve biz şok hâlindeyiz.
Yani ne?
Korktum mu, heyecanlandım mı?
Ne yapmam gerektiğini,
o an o duyguları size anlatamıyorum şu an;
çünkü inanın o duyguları tarif edemiyorum.
Ama mecburen gittim babamın yanına.
Dedim, ne oluyor.
Babam işte anlatıyor,
diyor "Bana hakaret etti,"
o oldu, bu oldu...
Dedim, durun.
Tabii muavin haklı olarak şikayetçi oldu.
Biz karakola.
Karakolda ifademizi verdik,
neyse yine olan oldu,
ama ben orada karakolda
şunu düşündüm.
Dedim ki yok,
hani ben niye o yaşta,
8 yaşındayım bu arada,
ben niye 8 yaşında bir adama,
duymayan bir adama çevirmenlik yapıyorum.
Burada olması gerekmiyor mu
o çevirmen?
Dedim, bunda bir hayır var,
devam edelim.
Sonra bir gün annem
menapoz evresine girdi.
Hastaneye gittik.
Hastanedeyiz;
doktor, ben ve annem.
O zaman da 10 yaşındayım.
Annemin menapozunu
anneme nasıl anlattığımı bilmiyorum,
ama anlattım.
Annem o devreyi o kadar rahat atlattı ki,
size anlatamam.
Ben bile şaşırdım,
ben bayağı iyiymişim dedim
kendi kendime.
O anda, o doktordan çıkış anımızda
şuna karar verdim:
ben sağır topluma
faydalı bir çevirmen olacağım
ve onlar için elimden gelen
her şeyi ve her şeyi yapacağım.
Tekrar söylüyorum,
dezavantajı olan ben,
bu dezavantajımı avantaja çevireceğim
deneyimleyerek, dedim
ve evet, çok özür dilerim.
Size bir konuda düzeltme yapmak istiyorum.
Aslında ben başta dedim ya
hani 2 çocuğum var diye,
yok benim iki çocuğum yok,
dört çocuğum var:
ikisi büyümekte olan kızlarım,
ikisi de benim kahramanlarım dediğim
yaşlanmakta olan annem ve babam.
Onların hayatları o kadar ilginç ki,
yani bizim ailede bizim eve girdiğiniz
zaman bir bakıyorsunuz ki
"Ay çok sessiz sakin bir ail"
diye düşünüyorsunuz,
ama bizim aile gerçekten çılgın bir aile.
Şu sebepten çılgın,
ben çocukkken hep şöyle düşünürdüm,
"Benim annem duyuyor."
ve abime derdim ki,
"Abi, bu annem bizi kandırıyor.
Biz hep annemle, yani ben "anne"
ne zaman desem, bana hemen dönüp bakıyor.
Bu annem beni kandırıyor."
Abim de hep aynı tavır.
"Neslihan saçmalama,
annem duymuyor.
Kadın sağır."
"Abi bak benle ısrar etme
ve gerçekten duyuyor."
Neyse bu büyüdükçe,
bu soru işareti bir an kayboldu gitti.
Anneanneler
torunlarına bakıyorlar maalesef
ister istemez çalışan anne olunca.
Küçük kızım,
bir gün bana şunu sordu.
Anne dedi,
anneannem duyuyor mu?
Dedim, duymuyor kızım saçmalama.
Yani aynı abimin cümleleri.
Kızım saçmalamasana
nereden duyacak, sağır işte.
Hayır anne, anneannem duyuyor
ve ben bu duyduğu olayı
size ispatlayacağım, dedi.
Dedim, buyur dükkan senin.
İstediğini yapabilirsin.
Küçük kızım okuldan çıkıyor,
o sıra annemle küçük kızım evde yalnız.
Küçük kızım sırtı dönük anneannesine.
Anneannesi de aynı şekilde,
yani birbirlerine sırtı dönük
şekilde oturuyorlar.
Küçük kızım önce şöyle diyor,
"Anneanne"
Annemde tabii ki
normal olarak tepki yok.
Sonra baskılı bir şekilde
"Anneanne!" diye seslendiğinde
annem akabinde dönüyor,
o ocakta olan yemeği
küçük kızımın ağzına tıkıyor.
Kızım o kadar şaşırıyor ki
ve o o anda diyor ki,
"Ya bak, gördünüz mü?"
Tabii bunda
bir ayrıntıyı söylemeyi unuttum.
Kızım o sıra
o olayı videoya çekiyor.
Bu videoyu
size göstermek isterdim ama,
maalesef kızımdan izin çıkmadığı için
bunu üzgünüm size gösteremiyorum.
Ama o hâli hayal etmenizi isterim,
o duymayan kadın birden dönüp
o ağzına yemeği koyması
küçük kızımın
kendini ispatladığını gösteriyor.
"Ben size demiştim,
anneannem duyuyor."
Ama ondan sonra, bu videoyu biz izledik
tabii önce bir gülme krizleri,
önce bir üzülme,
ama o soru işareti vardı ya
bir tane küçüklüğümden kalma.
O soru işareti tekrar aklımda
canlanmaya başladı gerçekten.
Ben annemi hayal ettiğim için
duyuyor sanıyordum,
ama gerçekten galiba
annem duyuyor benim.
İnanın ki duyuyor,
yani bizi kandırıyor şu an,
bize numara yapıyor.
Ben sağırım diye bizi üzüyor.
Üzmüyor da hani böyle
demagoji yapıyor diyelim.
Size sağır kültürüyle ilgili
küçük bir tüyo vermek istiyorum.
Bunu da yine yaşadığımız
bir anıyla anlatmak isterim.
Bir gün annemle evdeyiz,
sohbet ediyoruz.
O sıra kızlarım okuldan geliyor.
Yanında arkadaşları var.
Çocuklar işte kız arkadaşlarıyla
birlikte kızlar diyor ki,
"Anne biz korku filmi izleyeceğiz
ve bu korku filmini de
mutfakta izleyeceğiz."
Dedim, kızlar keyfinize bakın.
Biz yine salonda
annemle sohbet muhabbet.
O sıra, yani o vakitlerde
yakın bir vakitte babam dışarıdan çıkıyor,
pardon babam dışarıdan eve geliyor,
zile basıyor.
Zile bastığı an
mutfaktan bir çığlık kıyamet!
Dedim, noluyor bir şey mi oldu.
Mutfağa koşarken
büyük kızımın arkadaşlarına gülerek
bir şey izah ettiğini duymaya başladım.
Ne izah ediyordu,
biliyor musunuz?
"Arkadaşlar, zile bastığınızda
ışık yanması gayet normal.
Bu doğaüstü bir olay değil,
bu bizim dünyada yaşanan bir olay.
Yani bizim evde zile bastığınızda
entegre olmuş ışıkla,
aynı anda ışık yanar.
Hem zile basarsınız,
o anda ışığı yanar yanar ve görürsünüz."
Maalesef ki çocuklar çok korkmuş
ve orada bir çığlık kıyamet kopmuş,
ama büyük kızım gülmekten
bunu arkadaşlarına da izah edememiş.
Düşünüyoruz şimdi;
acaba bu bize gayet normal gelen bir şey,
niye insanlara
doğaüstü bir şey gibi geliyor?
Bu, şaşırtıcı gelmişti o sıra bize
ve benim arkadaşlarım ne zaman
oturup sohbet etsek bana şunu söyler:
"Ya sizin ev çok sessiz, değil mi?"
Siz de öyle düşünüyor olabilir misiniz
diye şu an kendimle çelişki hâlindeyim,
ama bizim ev sessiz değil.
Bizim ev gayet sesli,
gayet gürültülü;
çünkü benim bir tane kocaman
bir kahramanım var ya babam,
dev kahraman babam,
o babam gayet vurdumduymazdır.
Nasıl biliyor musunuz?
Masaya otururuz,
yemek yer ağzını şapırdatır.
Dışarıdan gelirken biz babamın
ayak seslerinden eve geldiğini duyarız.
Yani deriz ki,
kapı çalacak babam geldi.
Evet o an kapı çalar, babamdır
ve o biz gece o güzel uyku hâlinde,
o birden dolabın kapanması,
kapının şak diye kapanması,
bizi babamın vurdumduymazlığı
bizi artık tavan yaptırmıştır.
Babama hep şunu deriz:
Baba yeter, yorulduk.
Senin sessizliğin bizi sese boğdu,
yapma şunu.
Ama bir de şöyle düşünün,
bir de benim bir tane
küçük kahramanım daha var;
o bizim annemiz, pigmemiz.
Pigmemiz de
tam babamın zıt kutbudur.
Çok sessizdir, her an her yerden çıkar
ve sizi korkutabilir.
Yani o an biz böyleyiz,
"Ya anne nereden çıktın ya!
Bir dur, sakin ol."
Bir de boyu küçük ya,
pigmemiz ya,
bizi zıplatır her defasında.
O yüzden bizim evimiz her zaman sesli,
gürültülü ve eğlencelidir.
Biz kendi evimizde,
annemin babamın hep beraber olduğu evde,
çok eğleniriz.
Bu anlattıklarımdan sonra,
işaret dili çevirmeni olmanın
en güzel yanına geldim.
Bu ne biliyor musunuz?
Hayatta insanların önüne bir kapı çıkar.
Bu kapıyı açmak,
kapalı tutmak sizin elinizdedir.
İşte öyle bir kapı geldi benim önüme
ve ben bu kapıyı sonuna kadar
zorlayarak açık bıraktım.
Açmaya çalıştım
ve inanıyorum ki açtım.
O da şuydu:
Bir gün
Okan Bayülgen'in
programını seyrediyoruz,
hemen oraya gireceğim.
Sağır bir topluluk var.
Sağır topluluk sohbet ediyorlar;
sıkıntılarını, dertlerini,
ne yaşanması, ne yaşamamaları
gerektiğini anlatıyorlar
ve o an oradan bir sağır şunu söyledi:
"Ben sizi çok seviyorum,
ama sizi izleyemiyorum."
Orada Okan Bey bir kaldı.
Haklı.
İnsanların,
verilen haklarını kullanamaması
çok kötü bir durum.
O sağır grup da bunu ifade edince,
Okan Bey şöyle söyledi:
"Çılgın tercümanlar,
çılgın işaret dili çevirmenleri;
lütfen bana mail atın,
bundan sonra beraber çalışacağız."
Evet, doğru.
Belli bir dönem sonra bizi aradılar,
14 şubat günü
ve bizi programa davet ettiler.
O günden sonra,
o kapalı olan kapı var ya;
bizim için sağır toplumun
hep bir köşede kaldığı bir kapı vardı,
o kapıyı sonuna kadar açtık
ve sağır toplumun talk show'u,
haberleri
ve sizler gibi sevgili arkadaşların
onlarla iletişim kurmasını
ve köprü olmasını sağladım.
Evet,
bu kapı bir daha kapanmamak üzere
ne yapıyorum şu an;
eğitmenlik yapıyorum,
çevirmenlik yapmaya devam ediyorum
ve gençlerin, yani arkamdan gelen
genç arkadaşlarımın
önünü kapatmamak için
o kapıyı açık tutmaya çalışıyorum.
O kadar eğlenceli bir hayatımız
var ki bizim aslında,
o eğlenceli hayatın
sadece bir kısmını anlattım.
Belki size ilginç geldi,
bilmiyorum tabii duygularınızı.
İnşallah sizinle
iyi etkileşim olmuştur.
Size bir soru sormak istiyorum.
Siz de deneyimlemek ister misiniz
işaret dilini?
(Alkış)
Peki.
O zaman,
şöyle yapalım:
İşaret
dilini
seviyorum,
deneyimlemek
istiyorum.
Bir daha yapalım mı?
İşaret
dilini
seviyorum,
deneyimlemek
istiyorum.
Size bir tüyo daha vereyim.
Uluslararası "Seni seviyorum" demek,
"I love you"
Hepinizi çok seviyorum.
Görüşmek üzere.
(Alkış)